[Music]
Hey - verified welcome to handy panties
I'm so excited for this game 9 out of 10
I'm a mu weeaboo recommend it okay here
we are
okay how can we answer hi hello I think
I mean love and then they can't remember
my name right now I'll try that again
later looks like you're having some
trouble holding it together over there
I'm sure that's a fat load of [ __ ] and
you know it
[ __ ] you don't [ __ ] swear to me
[Music]
no way I got it go but we'll meet again
real soon trust is my favorite game of
all time what the [ __ ] you what are you
doing in my house I have to pull the
covers off where are you you recognize
this adorable face from the but of
course she drugged me son of a [ __ ] you
see as a love fairy it's my job to help
poor saps like
you out with the ladies it's just what I
do
seems very condescending I have a
girlfriend alright alright I'll try to
make this quick
it's an emu meets candy crush match
those for sexuality tokens what the [ __ ]
how many of you have just polished this
video right now to buy this game okay
now I give her a deep tipped a stuffed
beer all the parts I made a move I'm
making all the moves oh all the passion
baby who holds the affection baby moving
on the hunt
whenever I like the dick mode come on
[ __ ] is this
[Music]
there we go 100% baby what am i got
tissue pots and a dirty magazine oh yeah
just what I need and prepare them right
there okay great
okay thanks I gotta know what cup size
you're rocking do you prefer nannies how
old are you I'm 20 years old
mm-hmm [ __ ] please you look like 12 ask
an ID I'm ready to go that's really glad
you asked me out we're gonna date is
this a crime
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] it this game is so
inappropriate and so is this video but
that's why you love it what twelve right
like most guys you want to go about
[Music]
giving you yoga they don't deny a my own
about [ __ ] you an acceptance by a
lollipop a cookie some popcorn
that's no thanks what [ __ ] these birds
am i right
that worked no only kidding just thought
you were cute and wanted to meet you
okay okay she likes toys I'm pretty
[ __ ] irritable when I'm hungry or
anything also hungry okay chocolate
girls love chunk damn it I'm broke as a
mother [ __ ] hell
oh I can't wear this what are you
talking about you look you cute
stop there's nothing wrong with a little
skin you can't keep all that blue tear
spell cut it's not fair to the rest of
the world okay let's just focus we can
do this [ __ ] can you get me something to
eat
pretty please please eat this [ __ ]
burger later come on can we please hit
it off with one girl
oh that's appropriate date we're already
alright let's let's just do this
let's see I bet she likes fire yeah am
[Music]
oh hello no no no oh we're back in
business baby
eight more moves come on you can do this
browse get breathe race to my family
it's not gonna be able to look like I
[Music]
unlocked her playful bunny outfit
all right price get out there medic but
oh man
don't tell my dia did I play this and
live a like if you want more kitty I
mean more of this game and I will see
you pros in the next one thanks for
watching I was appreciated stay awesome
bros that [ __ ] is coming down there why
is that bra floating in the air the
image you got away I mean hey what you
doin i visit get rack